We just had a great conversation yesterday
with David Roberts from Vox about the irrelevance
of facts in deciding what is one's truth in
the era of Trump. And David pointed out a
stupidly, I think it's not that facts don't
matter. It's that the definition of what constitutes
a fact has become completely fluid in the
minds of Trumpists who are determined to defend
Donald Trump. No matter what he does. It's
the circular reasoning of if it sounds like
a lie, we're being deceived that it's a lie.
The lie is that Trump is a liar, so to speak.
Donald Trump is now straight up saying it
doesn't matter if he lies to his followers
and to the country as long as he come up can
come up with some defense of why he lied.
So there's a few ways that people in the public
eye can handle, uh, being accused of saying
something untrue. You can deny that you said
something untrue. You can deny that what you
said was untrue, claiming it was actually
the truth. And you can also say, I lied, but
it doesn't matter that I lied. And that's
what Donald Trump is doing about the justification
for assassinating a rainy in general Kaseem
Solemani without congressional authorization.
So the first justification was Kaseem. Soleimani
had to be taken out. He was an imminent threat
to the U S planning attacks. Eventually mentioned
planning attacks on multiple us embassies
around the world. While Donald Trump was still
repeating that justification, his own secretary
of state, Mike Palm PEO, started using a different
justification, which was, we took out Sola
Amani because of his history of doing bad
things. Now taking him out because things
of things he did in the past is very different
than saying he was imminently planning an
attack on the United States or its assets.
Of course, this immediately became a topic
of discussion because first Donald Trump doesn't
get congressional authorization for the assassination,
which he said under Barack Obama presidents
need to do. Then he says, the justification
was imminent danger. Then they change and
say, well, it was the stuff that he did in
the past, but then done. Donald Trump actually
tweets. You know, it really doesn't matter
what explanation I give. It doesn't matter
whether it's true or it isn't tweeting. A
day and a half ago, the fake news media and
their Democrat partners are working hard to
determine whether or not the future attack
by terrorists Soleimani was imminent or not,
and was my team in agreement the answers to
both as a strong yes, but it doesn't really
matter because of his horrible past. It actually
does matter. Here is Donald Trump talking
to Laura Ingram a few days ago, asked by Laura
Ingram, don't Americans deserve to know why
you really assassinated him without congressional
authorization? That's my wording, not hers.
Donald Trump said, no, they don't.
Don't. The American people have a right to
know what specifically was targeted without
revealing methods and sources? Well, I don't
think so, but we will tell you that probably
it was going to be the embassy in Baghdad.
You saw that happening. You saw with all of
the men, very few women circling it and circling
it very strongly and very viciously.
Trump says, no, they
don't have a right to know, but I'll feed
you a lie anyway. First, the strike was an
authorized by Congress. That's a problematic.
Then the Trump administration gives conflicting
justification for why the strike happened.
That matters. Trump risk war, if he's risking
war to prevent actual imminent harm to the
United States, that's very different than
simply choosing a politically convenient time
to assassinate a bad guy without the authorization
he claimed he needed. Now, it just so happens
that the imminent threat explanation is bogus.
Multiple officials from the Pentagon have
said there was no evidence of an imminent
threat. There was no evidence that embassies
were about to be targeted. There is no evidence
of any of it. So when a Trump is says, that's
right, throw credibility in the trash. Whatever
Trump says was the uh, reason he assassinated
Soleimani. Doesn't matter even if it's a lie,
because Sola Mani was a bad guy.
What Trumpists are saying is it's fine that
the president lies not for national security
reasons, not because of sensitive classified
information. It's fine that he lies just for
the hell of it. And for a political movement
that claims to hate postmodernism. Most of
them don't even know the term, but those that
do claim to hate it, they are very comfortable
playing fast and loose with the definition
of reality and fact and empiricism and just
calling things what they are. And Trump is
right in a sense it doesn't matter to his
followers. If he lies or tells the truth,
they don't care. They will find a way to support
them, no matter what. They will find ways
to excuse his lies or simply to claim that
they are not lies, which is why we've got
to go around them. In removing Donald Trump
by voting in November of 2020